There's a lot of noise in our graph since we are
plotting the mean of y for every possible tenure x value.
Recall from lesson four that we can adjust this noise by
bending our x-axis differently. Let me show you one of those changes
in the bend width. Here's our code from before, and instead
of using tenure here, I'm going to replace this with a different version
or formula so that way I can bend some of the
tenures together. Now let's see the difference when I plot this graph.
Notice how I have slightly less noise in my plot.
We still see some of the same peaks from before,
especially here, but it's much smoother in general. Here's another
one using the number 30 instead of the number seven
and here's a graph with very high bias, but much
less variance using the number 90. Here I plotted all
the graphs so we could compare it to the original
one. Notice that as the bin size increases we see less
noise on the plot. Our estimates are adjusted
since we have more data points for our new
values of tenure. In lesson four we introduce
smoothers as one tool for an analyst to use
in these types of situations. So instead of
using gm line here, I'd like you to use
gm smooth, to add a smoother, to this
plot. Try doing this, in this next programming assignment.